OK, you know the rules. No smoking in here. Cell phones off. No talking during the show. Ready? OK, let's roll the film. This is a home movie, and it looks like any other home movie. People at a summer resort. White cottages with screened-in porches and red roofs. There's a woman with an 18-month-old girl running around.
好的，你知道规矩。这里禁止吸烟。手机关机。放映期间禁止说话。准备好了吗？好的，电影开演吧。这是一部家庭录像，它看起来和别的家庭录像没什么两样。人们在避暑胜地。有着带纱窗门廊和红色屋顶的白色小屋。有个女人带着一个 18 个月大的女孩在四处跑。
There I am. Aren't I cute? Look at that. Chubby. Some things just don't change.
那是我。我不可爱吗？看那个。胖乎乎的。有些事情就是不会改变。
Kathy Alexander is the 18-month-old in the film, now all grown up. What interests her in this film is the woman. Kathy is adopted, and she thinks that this woman, whose name she does not know, might be her real mother. The woman's face is mostly obscured because they're in the shade. It's fuzzy. The film's old, and Kathy strains to see the resemblance.
凯西·亚历山大就是影片里那个 18 个月大的女孩，现在已经长大了。她对这部影片感兴趣的是那个女人。凯西是被领养的，她认为这个连名字都不知道的女人，可能是她的亲生母亲。那个女人的脸大部分被遮住了，因为她们在阴影里。画面很模糊。影片很老了，凯西努力想从中看出相似之处。
Oh, here she is. See, almost right in here, you could see her face. And if I could just get that lightened-- some point right here-- see, what happens is, it's lighter, and again, there's my profile. And then right here, this right here, is my posture. Just looking at that looks like I'm looking at myself on one of my other home videos. And here-- if you could take a look, if I can even just show you that thigh. I mean, nobody's got thighs like that. Those are mine. That's a hereditary feature because I could see my daughter has, just like I did.
噢，她在这儿。你看，就在这儿，几乎能看到她的脸。如果我能把光调亮一点——就在这儿——看，发生什么了，这里更亮一点，还有，那是我的侧脸。然后就在这儿，这一点，是我的姿势。光是看着这个，就像在看我其他家庭录像里的自己。还有这儿——如果你能看看，如果我能给你看那个大腿。我是说，没人有那样的大腿。那是我的。那是遗传特征，因为我能看到我女儿也有，就像我小时候一样。
She watches this minute of film over and over. She gives copies of it to friends the way that other people hand out pictures of their kids. It's one of the most important things she owns. But to look at it, you'd never know because all home movies look alike. When they mean anything, it's small and it's private. The pictures themselves don't tell much. You know what I'm talking about.
她一遍又一遍地看这一分钟的录像。她像别人分发孩子照片那样把拷贝送给朋友。这是她拥有的最重要的东西之一。但你看的时候，你永远不会知道，因为所有家庭录像看起来都一样。当它们有意义时，那也是微小且私人的。画面本身讲不出太多东西。你知道我在说什么。
Birthday parties, weddings, rites of passage. First steps. Babies in bassinets.
生日派对，婚礼，成长仪式。蹒跚学步。摇篮里的婴儿。
Alan Berliner spent six years of his life going around finding old home movies and watching them and collecting them and finally condensing them into this amazing film that he called Family Album.
艾伦·伯林纳花了他生命中六年的时间四处寻找旧家庭录像，观看、收集，最终将它们浓缩成这部他称之为《家庭相册》的神奇影片。
There's invariably the baby that they put on the back of the family dog.
总会有那个被他们放在家庭宠物狗背上的婴儿。
That's a standard shot? You've seen that a lot?
那是标准镜头吗？你见过很多次？
I've seen several of that. Yes. The beach is also big, big.
我见过好几次。是的。海滩也是重头戏，非常重。
Big.
非常。
Big time beach. Summer beach.
海滩重头戏。夏季海滩。
The beach figures bigger into our home movies than into our lives.
海滩在我们家庭录像中的戏份比在我们生活中还要重。
Yeah, I would say. Swimming is a big thing that Earthlings do, according to home movies. Life on earth is a life of leisure without struggle that, again, mostly takes place in the summer, in the water, at beaches, or around pools. Home movies are also primarily about children. Perhaps 60%, 70% percent of home movies contain images of children, I would say up to about the age of 12 or so. And then it stops.
是啊，我会这么说。根据家庭录像，游泳是地球人做的一件大事。地球上的生活是一种没有挣扎的闲暇生活，再次强调，它大多发生在夏天，在水里，在海滩上，或者在泳池边。家庭录像也主要是关于孩子的。我会说，60% 到 70% 的家庭录像包含孩子们的影像，大概到 12 岁左右。然后就停止了。
In fact, I've seen many, many collections of home movies, and they'll be-- for argument's sake, imagine a girl named Adrian. The cans will be labeled, "Adrian, Age 1," "Adrian, Age 2," "Age 3," "Age 4." And at about age 11 or 12, it stops. There's no more Adrian until, perhaps, she gets married. And that's because puberty happens, adolescence happens, and you suddenly have a kind of tension within the family in terms of the relation between parent and child.
事实上，我见过许多许多家庭录像合集，它们会是——比方说，想象一个叫艾德丽安的女孩。带子会被贴上标签，“艾德丽安，1岁”，“艾德丽安，2岁”，“3岁”，“4岁”。在大约 11 或 12 岁时，就停了。再也没有艾德丽安了，直到也许她结婚的时候。这是因为青春期发生了，青少年时期发生了，你突然在家庭内部，在父母和孩子之间产生了一种紧张关系。
So when there are kids in the films, they're cute and they're little and they're happy.
所以当影片里有孩子时，他们很可爱，很小，很快乐。
All the time. All the time.
一直如此。一直如此。
Home movies are a family's way of preserving, forever, the thought, we were a nice family. We loved each other. Any feeling, any fact, about the family besides that fact, generally does not make it into the films. And that's as true, Alan Berliner says, of the black and white films that he's watched from the 1920s as the videos taken last month at his niece's birthday party.
家庭录像是一个家庭永远保留这种想法的方式：我们是一个幸福的家庭。我们彼此相爱。除了这个事实之外，关于家庭的任何感受、任何事实，通常都不会出现在影片中。艾伦·伯林纳说，这不仅适用于他观看过的 1920 年代的黑白影片，也适用于上个月在他侄女生日派对上拍的录像。
Because all the images in everybody's home movies are the same, because the pictures are all the same, all the meaning comes from things that are not in the pictures, which makes them, I have to say, the perfect subject for a radio show. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Home Movies, what they say in spite of themselves. We bring you five movies for radio in five acts, including stories from David Sedaris and Jonathan Goldstein, a look at the cinematic output of 12-year-old auteurs, and what the producers of America's Funniest Home Videos know about America that you don't. Stay with us.
因为每个人家庭录像里的画面都是一样的，因为照片都一样，所有的意义都来自于画面之外的东西，这让我不得不说，它们是广播节目的完美主题。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是《家庭录像》，它们在不经意间诉说着什么。我们为您带来五幕广播电影，包括大卫·塞达里斯和乔纳森·戈德斯坦的故事，看看 12 岁的小导演们的电影作品，以及《全美最有趣家庭录像》的制作者们对美国了解而你不知道的事情。请继续收听。
Act One, The Big Night. We thought that we should begin today's program with one of the classic, typical kinds of home movies, a video of a holiday meal, a family meal. All the relatives sitting around the table. I'm sure that you have seen these at some point from Thanksgivings or Christmases. There are not many videos from the Jewish New Year dinner, Rosh Hashanah, a big family event, one of the big Jewish holidays, partly because Jewish law prohibits using a video camera or any other machine on that holy day. That did not stop Jonathan Goldstein's family from filming one.
第一幕，大日子。我们想以一种经典、典型的家庭录像来开始今天的节目，一段节日晚餐，家庭聚餐的视频。所有的亲戚围坐在桌子旁。我相信你们在感恩节或圣诞节时看过这些。关于犹太新年的晚餐，赎罪日，一个大型家庭活动，犹太教的大节日之一，并没有多少视频，部分原因是犹太法律禁止在那个神圣的日子使用摄像机或任何机器。但这并没有阻止乔纳森·戈德斯坦的家人拍摄了其中一场。
When I was a teenager, the Rosh Hashanah tape was the first thing I'd show any new girlfriend. It was a primer on my family that I felt they would need to see in order to best understand me. In showing them the tape, it was like I wanted to make them understand that no matter how messed up I was, all things considered, I really could have been a lot worse. It's been about 10 years since I've looked at the tape.
当我还是个青少年时，那盘赎罪日的录像带是我会给任何新女友看的第一样东西。那是我家庭的入门指南，我觉得她们需要看这个才能更好地了解我。给她们看带子的时候，就好像我想让她们明白，无论我多么糟糕，总的来说，我其实可能更糟糕。距离我上次看那盘带子已经过去大约 10 年了。
Are you filming me?
你在拍我吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Johnny, put that away, come on.
强尼，把它收起来，得了吧。
The night begins with a feeling of expectation, everyone preparing for the big night. My mother clears stacks of laundry off the dining room table. With a great show of ceremony, she and my father moved the plastic-covered red velvet couch away from the wall and pull out the extra dining room table leaves from behind it. We'd only use the table twice a year.
那个夜晚以一种期待感开始，每个人都在为大日子做准备。我母亲把餐桌上的几堆衣物挪开。她带着极大的仪式感，和父亲把靠墙的塑料封套红色天鹅绒沙发移开，从后面拉出额外的餐桌板。我们一年只用两次那张桌子。
All the way?
一直到底了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Later in the evening, people start to arrive. When I'd show this to girlfriends, I would freeze-frame on each of the cast and explain a bit about them. This is my uncle Lou, I'd say. On the night of his mother's death, he ate an entire brisket, so great was his grief.
那天晚上晚些时候，人们开始陆续到达。当我给女朋友看这些时，我会暂停每一位出场人物，解释一下他们。这是路易叔叔，我会说。在他母亲去世的那个晚上，他吃下了一整块牛胸肉，他的悲伤就是如此巨大。
Hi, kid. Say hi.
嗨，孩子。打个招呼。
Don't give me a close-up because my eyes are too ugly for close-ups.
别给我特写，因为我的眼睛太丑了，不适合特写。
Placing the camera up to my eye and squinting into it like that felt good, the way it covered up my face like a mask and stuffed the whole Yiddish circus of my family into a tidy, manageable, little frame that I could fade in and out at will.
把摄像机放在眼边，像那样眯着眼看感觉很好，它像面具一样遮住了我的脸，把我家庭的整个犹太马戏团塞进了一个整洁、可控的小框架里，我可以随意淡入淡出。
That camera has everything on it, everything.
那台摄像机什么功能都有，什么都有。
Has it got a stand too?
它有支架吗？
You named the one thing it doesn't have.
你点出了它唯一没有的东西。
Early on in the night, I filmed my mother in the kitchen.
那天晚上很早的时候，我拍了厨房里的母亲。
[SINGING]
[唱歌]
She dances around and sings for the camera while preparing dinner. My grandmother walks in at one point and asks her where the Kleenex is, and my mother tells her to use toilet paper.
她一边准备晚餐，一边绕着摄像机跳舞唱歌。外婆在某个时候走进来，问她纸巾在哪儿，母亲让她用卫生纸。
No, go use toilet paper. [SINGING]
不，去用卫生纸。[唱歌]
In our house, whether you were blowing your nose, mopping up spilled pea soup, or bandaging a head injury, it was toilet paper. As a kid, I was embarrassed by this. Toilet paper. It sounded so personal. And pulling it out of my lunch bag to use as a napkin in the high school cafeteria brought just enough of my family bathroom to the table to make those around me lose their appetite.
在我们家，不管是擦鼻涕、擦掉洒出的豌豆汤，还是包扎头部伤口，用的都是卫生纸。小时候我为此感到尴尬。卫生纸。听起来太私密了。把它从午餐袋里掏出来当餐巾纸在高中食堂用，带给周围人的家庭洗手间的气息足以让他们失去食欲。
My mother singing and dancing around the house was another point of embarrassment for me as a kid. I felt like watching her sing "Let's Get Physical" while cooking pancakes was a mild form of child abuse. Watching her now on the tape, I realize she was singing, not because she was crazy, but because she was actually happy. Both her parents were still alive, so she'd let herself act like someone's little kid sometimes. I haven't seen her sing like that in years.
母亲在家绕着圈唱歌跳舞是我小时候另一个尴尬点。我觉得看她一边做煎饼一边唱《让我们动起来》是一种轻微的虐童行为。现在看着带子里的她，我意识到她唱歌不是因为她疯了，而是因为她真的很开心。她父母那时都还健在，所以她有时会让自己表现得像别人的小孩子一样。我已经好多年没见过她那样唱歌了。
The presence of the video camera puts my great-aunt Simi in a time capsule-y kind of mood. She decides to tell this story about her son for posterity, so my father helps her shout the table down.
摄像机的存在让西米姨婆有一种时光胶囊般的心情。她决定为了后代讲讲她儿子的故事，所以我父亲帮她压住桌子上的喧闹。
Let Simi talk.
让西米说。
When Jeffrey was four years old, we went downtown. And we were caught in the rain waiting for the bus. So there was a Reichmann's store on St. Lawrence and St. Catherine, with a little hallway, so we went in to wait. And there was a display in the windows of lady's lingerie and everything. He looks in the window, and there's men and women shielding themselves from the rain. "Mommy, what's that?"
杰弗里四岁的时候，我们去市中心。我们在雨中等公交车。圣劳伦斯和圣凯瑟琳路口有一家莱希曼商店，带一个小走廊，所以我们进去等。橱窗里陈列着女士内衣之类的东西。他看着橱窗，有男男女女在躲雨。“妈妈，那是什么？”
I take a look, and I give his hand a jerk. I say, "Nothing." "Oh, you know. You know. You have it in your drawer." Guess what it was? A pair of falsies.
我看了一眼，拽了一下他的手。我说，“没什么。”“噢，你知道。你知道。你的抽屉里就有。”猜猜那是什么？一对义乳。
Oh, is that something else?
噢，那是别的什么吗？
When I was a teenager, right here is where I'd pause the tape. I would freeze-frame the image of my great-aunt Simi, mouth open, just about to pop in an olive. With that as my backdrop, I would tell the story of how, when I was a child, Simi would command me to pinch her buttocks. "You can't pinch it," she'd cry, "and that is because it is too tight. Go ahead." "Keep trying. Keep trying," she'd continue, her face all clenched like a fist, all determined to make her buttocks as hard as a cantaloupe. In her slippery, skin-tight polyester slacks, trying to get a piece of my aunt's ass was as elusive as pinching a helium-filled balloon. Now, watching the tape with friends a half-generation later, I'm not going to lie to you, that story still kills.
当我还是个青少年时，我就会在这儿暂停带子。我会定格西米姨婆的画面，她嘴巴张着，正要吃下一颗橄榄。以那为背景，我会讲我小时候的故事，西米会命令我去捏她的屁股。“你捏不动，”她会叫道，“那是因为它太紧了。来吧。”“继续试。继续试，”她会继续说，脸像拳头一样紧绷，决心要把她的屁股练得像哈密瓜一样硬。穿着她那滑溜溜、紧贴皮肤的涤纶长裤，想要抓住我姨妈的屁股就像捏住一个充氦气球一样难以捉摸。现在，在半代人之后和朋友们看这盘带子，我不会骗你，那个故事依然好笑得要命。
Incidentally, I should also say that Simi was the first person who ever really felt me up. Bored at my uncle Harry's Shiva house, she decided to check and see what was in the front pockets of my pants. She uncovered gum wrappers, old movie stubs, and a surprising amount of toilet paper, which she emptied out onto the kitchen table in three glorious scoops that I later referred to as my real bar mitzvah.
顺便说一句，我也该说西米是第一个真正摸我的人。在哈里叔叔的守丧期感到无聊时，她决定检查一下我裤子前兜里有什么。她翻出了口香糖纸、旧电影票根，还有数量惊人的卫生纸，她分三下壮观地掏出来放在餐桌上，我后来称之为我真正的受诫礼。
Who made this marble cake?
这大理石蛋糕是谁做的？
Steve and Lisa's brother-in-law's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
史蒂夫和丽莎姐夫的[听不清]。
This is excellent.
这太棒了。
I should probably also tell you that the entire Rosh Hashanah meal is consumed in 15 minutes flat. I mean the whole thing, the gefilte fish entree, the salad, the handmade coleslaw, the bean and barley soup, and the main course. 15 minutes. I remember the TV was on in the basement, and Jeopardy had just started. By the time it was Double Jeopardy, we were eating dessert. But then, paradoxically, dessert was something that lingered on and on.
我还应该告诉你们，整顿赎罪日大餐是在 15 分钟内吃完的。我是说整个过程，冻鱼前菜，沙拉，手工凉拌卷心菜，豆子大麦汤，还有主菜。15 分钟。我记得楼下的电视开着，《危险边缘》刚开始。等到《双倍危险边缘》时，我们已经在吃甜点了。但矛盾的是，甜点却持续了很久很久。
What are these? Moon cookies? Who made these moon cookies? They're out of this world.
这些是什么？月亮曲奇？谁做的这些月亮曲奇？简直太好吃了。
My grandfather ate dessert alone in the basement, so he could watch baseball. My grandfather was of the mind that no one up there listened to him anyway, so he pretty much stopped trying. He spoke through his actions, random outrageous incomprehensible actions. Like if he was tired and wanted you to get out of his house, he would come out wearing just his boxer shorts and sit right down beside you on the couch. You would collect your things, and you would leave.
外公独自在地下室吃甜点，这样他就能看棒球。外公觉得反正楼上没人听他的，所以他基本放弃了尝试。他通过行动说话，随机的、离谱的、不可理喻的行动。比如如果他累了，想让你离开他家，他就会只穿着平角内裤出来，直接坐在沙发上你旁边。你就会收拾东西，然后离开。
This next part of the tape, of him and me in the basement, I never made jokes about. I was so embarrassed by my inability to make simple man-to-man chitchat with my grandfather that when screening the tape I would often just fast-forward through the whole scene because it pained me so. It was just around the whole Pete Rose gambling scandal.
带子上接下来这一部分，我和他在地下室，我从来不开玩笑。我对自己无法和外公进行简单的成年人谈话感到如此尴尬，以至于在放映带子时，我经常直接快进掉整个场景，因为这让我太痛苦了。那正好是皮特·罗斯赌博丑闻期间。
They showed him on the cover of Time, crying.
他们让他在《时代》周刊封面上哭泣。
That's what they call it? Crying?
他们管那叫什么？哭泣？
Well, whatever it is. I'm sure he's very disappointed actually.
好吧，不管是什么。我相信他真的很失望。
This is what most of our conversations were like at the time. He would stare at the TV, and I would get all sweaty, trying my hardest to talk about anything I could think of that had to do with sports. Since I never watched them, nor did I play them, my talk revolved around the girlier aspects of sports, the scandals, the exorbitant pay raises, the poem I might have seen Muhammad Ali recite on The Mike Douglas Show. And all the while, my grandfather just sat there.
这就是那时我们大部分对话的样子。他盯着电视，而我紧张得汗流浃背，竭尽全力想谈任何我能想到的跟体育有关的话题。因为我从不看体育比赛，也不参与，我的谈话内容围绕着体育中比较女性化的方面：丑闻、过高的薪水加成、我可能在迈克·道格拉斯秀上看到穆罕默德·阿里朗诵的诗。而在此期间，我外公只是坐在那儿。
He was a legend.
他是传奇。
Hall-of-Famer.
名人堂成员。
Well, they can't omit him from that. That's up to the critics, I think.
好吧，他们不能忽略他。那是评论家们的事，我想。
I have no idea what the hell I'm talking about. Watching the video all these years later, actually 13 years after my grandfather's death, I realize in retrospect that this was around the time he was diagnosed with leukemia. No wonder he didn't want to talk. No wonder he went to the basement. At the time, except for my grandmother, he had told no one. Those kinds of personal things weren't ever talked about in the open. When we all got together, we argued about where the best place to buy a roast chicken was or what was on TV.
我根本不知道我在胡说八道什么。多年以后看这段视频，实际上是在外公去世 13 年后，我事后才意识到那时正是他被诊断出患有白血病的时候。难怪他不想说话。难怪他要去地下室。当时，除了外婆，他没告诉任何人。那种私人的事情从来不在公开场合讨论。当我们聚在一起时，我们为了去哪儿买烤鸡最好或者电视上播什么而争论。
Well, did you see her today, Oprah, about them?
那么，你今天看奥普拉了吗，关于他们的？
No, they don't get big.
不，他们不会长大的。
This guy had a big one, and that guy has a small one.
那个人有一个大的，那个人有一个小的。
No one gets to finish a story. Conversation is like this verbal game of murderball, back and forth, everybody shouting over everybody else, nobody really listening to anybody. But it goes further than even that. Here's my mother and her aunt Simi sitting side by side on the living room couch with my grandmother, all of them kind of staring off into space after the huge dinner. Then suddenly, apropos to nothing, one of them starts singing "White Christmas." Then the other one, as though sitting on a different couch in a different universe, as if the thought had just arrived from out of the blue, pipes up with the exact same song, never looking at the other, never acknowledging she's there.
没人能把故事讲完。谈话就像这种名为“谋杀球”的语言游戏，来来回回，每个人都在打断别人大喊大叫，没人真正听别人说话。但它甚至不仅限于此。这是我母亲和她的姨妈西米，还有我外婆坐在客厅沙发上，在丰盛的晚餐后都盯着虚空。然后突然，毫无征兆地，其中一个人开始唱《白色圣诞节》。然后另一个人，就像坐在不同宇宙的另一张沙发上，仿佛这个想法刚从天而降，也唱起了同一首歌，从来不看对方，也不承认对方在那儿。
[SINGING] I'm dreaming of a white Christmas--
[唱歌] 我梦想着一个白色圣诞节——
[SINGING] --just like the ones--
[唱歌] ——就像那些——
[SINGING] --just like the ones we used to know.
[唱歌] ——就像那些我们曾经熟悉的。
[SINGING] --I used to know.
[唱歌] ——我曾经熟悉的。
Let's not even get into the fact that, one, they're singing a Christmas carol in the middle of September, and two, it also happens to be the holiest night on the Jewish calendar.
我们甚至不用谈论这样一个事实：第一，他们在九月中旬唱圣诞颂歌；第二，那天正好是犹太历中最神圣的夜晚。
What all this chaos leads to, the logical climax in consequence of the entire evening, is when, in the middle of dinner, my father gets it into his head that right now, at that very instant, he was going to fix the loose knob on the front door. The doorknob had been loose for years at this point, and why he decided to fix it just then, to this day, he cannot say. So my father goes downstairs into the garage to get his toolbox, which, to be fair, isn't actually a literal toolbox, but a plastic lunch pail which contains a wrench, a pair of rusty pliers, a plastic 12-inch ruler, and a screwdriver. The camera casually pans past a wall of neatly-stacked spare toilet paper on the garage shelves. My uncle Lou decides to help.
所有这一切混乱导致的结果，整晚逻辑上的高潮后果是，在晚餐进行到一半时，我父亲突发奇想，就在那一刻，他要去修前门那个松动的把手。门把手当时已经松动多年了，他为什么偏偏在那时决定修理它，直到今天他都说不上来。于是我父亲下楼去车库拿工具箱，说实话，那其实不是真正的工具箱，而是一个塑料饭盒，里面装着一把扳手、一把生锈的钳子、一把 12 英寸的塑料尺和一把螺丝刀。摄像机随意扫过车库架子上整齐堆放的备用卫生纸。路易叔叔决定帮忙。
These screwdrivers are [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. No, that isn't the one I want.
这些螺丝刀是[听不清]。不，那不是我要的那把。
Well, tighten the thing here.
好吧，把这东西拧紧。
Now, let me make this as clear as I can. When my father and Lou first started working on the doorknob, the time code in the corner of the video screen reads 6:27. They would only finish two and a half hours later, and almost all of which time my father spent on his knees turning the doorknob screw around and around, for the most part, in the same continuous direction.
现在，让我尽量说清楚。我父亲和路易第一次开始修门把手时，视频屏幕角落的时间码显示是 6:27。他们两个半小时后才完成，而我父亲几乎所有时间都跪在地上，不断地转动门把手上的螺丝，大部分时间里，都是朝着同一个连续方向。
Just a minute.
稍等一下。
He's taking pictures with the thing.
他在用那东西拍照。
I'm going to go down and get-- Johnny, please, excuse me.
我要下去拿——强尼，拜托，失陪一下。
The other guests sing more songs, try on clothes, exchange recipes, take third and fourth helpings of dessert. And through all of it, my dad turning and turning like a Jewish Lady Macbeth, one who's abandoned murder for home repair. At some point, people start to funnel out the door to go home.
其他客人在唱更多的歌，试穿衣服，交流食谱，吃第三次、第四次甜点。而在这一切之中，我父亲像个犹太版的麦克白夫人一样转呀转，一个为了居家维修而放弃谋杀的麦克白夫人。在某个时刻，人们开始从门外疏散回家。
Lou, good night.
路易，晚安。
Good night.
晚安。
Buzz, take care.
巴兹，保重。
OK, take care.
好的，保重。
They shuffle around his kneeling body and say goodbye, like none of this is at all strange.
他们在他跪着的身体周围走动并告别，好像这一切一点也不奇怪。
Good night.
晚安。
Bye-bye sweetheart.
再见，亲爱的。
My father does not look up, still hypnotized by the turning of the screw. When I try to tear him  away from the job, he tells me he can't help it. It's an emergency.
我父亲没有抬头，依然被螺丝的转动催眠了。当我试图把他从工作中拉开时，他告诉我他没法帮忙。这是紧急情况。
Is that turning? That's OK. That's turning.
那是转了吗？没关系。那转了。
Is that turning?
那是转了吗？
That's turning.
那是转了。
So I thought this was the end of the whole thing. But having not seen the tape in over 10 years, I've forgotten that I also videoed the second night of Rosh Hashanah. So I keep watching, and then I see something that I have absolutely no memory of whatsoever. Sitting at the dining room table, sandwiched between my sister and grandmother, is this entire British family.
所以我以为这就是整件事的结局了。但因为有 10 多年没看这盘带子了，我忘了我也拍了赎罪日的第二天。所以我继续看，然后看到了一些我完全没有记忆的东西。坐在餐桌旁，夹在我姐姐和外婆中间的，是这一整个英国家庭。
Do you brush it after you wash it?
你洗完头会梳它吗？
I brush it, and I put in big, big rollers.
我梳它，然后用大大的发卷。
There's an older Englishman, well-groomed and proper, sitting there sipping wine and actually sporting an ascot. There's his wife, an animated woman who chain smokes Virginia Slims, and their daughter, a woman who actually tells anecdotes about current events and expresses genuine interest in my video making.
有一个上了年纪的英国人，穿着考究，得体，坐在那里喝着酒，甚至还戴着领巾。还有他的妻子，一个抽着维吉尼亚纤细香烟的活泼女人，以及他们的女儿，一个讲述时事轶事并对我的摄像表达了真诚兴趣的女人。
Well, I know my father, what he did was he had a lot of eight-millimeter old movies from where I was growing up.
好吧，我了解我父亲，他所做的是他有很多 8 毫米的旧电影，记录了我成长过程中的点滴。
It's like they wandered off the set of a different home movie and into ours. And the strangest part of the whole thing is that everyone's acting like nothing unusual is going on.
就好像他们从另一部家庭录像的片场溜进了我们这部。最奇怪的部分是每个人表现得好像什么不同寻常的事情都没发生一样。
Do you drink tea or coffee?
你喝茶还是咖啡？
Tea. As well as drinking tea, we drink amaretto, and everyone is bumming cigarettes off the old British woman. All of a sudden, we're all having a grand time. Even my grandfather is. Instead of sitting in the basement, he's asking genial questions like:
茶。除了喝茶，我们还喝苦杏酒，每个人都在蹭那位老英国女人的烟抽。突然之间，我们都玩得很开心。连我外公也是。他不再坐在地下室，而是问一些和蔼的问题，比如：
Who made this beautiful apple cake?
这漂亮的苹果蛋糕是谁做的？
It turns out the British family were my Uncle Melvin's in-laws, who were in from out of town. The evening plays out like that old Disney movie, Song of the South . The British are what appear to be real normal people, and my family are like the cartoon bluebirds fluttering around them, trying in earnest to keep them entertained.
原来那个英国家庭是我梅尔文叔叔的亲家，是从外地来的。那个夜晚的展开就像那部古老的迪士尼电影《南方之歌》。英国人看起来是真正正常的人，而我的家人就像环绕在他们周围的卡通蓝知更鸟，认真地试图让他们保持娱乐。
I use one [? schmuck ?] per week. Last year, I used to use 10 a day.
我每周用一个[听不清]。去年，我一天用 10 个。
I don't remember filming this, but I'm certain I identified with the normal people, not with the cartoon birds. I remember looking through the camera at my family and feeling like I was a million miles away, like I was looking into the large end of a telescope. It made me feel like less a part of them, like more of just an observer. But then there's one moment near the end of the night, where I hand the video camera over to my grandmother, a total old-country technophobe, so she could film me.
我不记得拍这个了，但我肯定我认同那些正常人，而不是卡通鸟。我记得透过摄像机看着我的家人，感觉就像我在一百万英里之外，就像我透过望远镜的大端向里看。这让我觉得自己不像他们的一部分，更像是一个观察者。但就在夜晚快结束时，有那么一刻，我把摄像机交给了外婆，一个完全的老派科技恐惧症患者，让她拍我。
Now you're filming me, right now. You see?
现在你在拍我，就在现在。你看？
I have to close--
我必须关掉——
And when you want to stop it, you press the red button again.
当你想要停止时，再按一次红色按钮。
OK. Go-- yeah, move around a bit.
好的。开始——是的，走动一下。
And there I am, moving around with my tapered pants, jelly bracelets, and long moussed-up '80s hair, which, in retrospect, actually looked a lot like my mother's perm. Watching the video, I see the way my grandfather gritted his teeth when he stretched, or how he did this thing with his shoulders when he drank something that was too hot, and it's just the way I do it. Here I am, comparing wrist size with my father.
然后就是我，穿着锥形裤，戴着果冻手镯，留着长长的 80 年代摩丝发型，回想起来，看起来确实很像我母亲的烫发。看着视频，我看到外公伸懒腰时紧咬牙关的样子，或者他喝太烫的东西时耸肩的样子，和我一模一样。这就是我，和我父亲比较手腕大小。
Look at this. It runs in the family maybe. Oh, no, you've got a very thick wrist. That's a thick wrist. I think on Mommy's side of the family, we have thin wrists. I told you, I've got very thin wrists.
看这个。也许是遗传。噢，不，你的手腕很粗。那是粗手腕。我想在妈那边的家族里，我们手腕很细。我告诉过你，我的手腕很细。
Posed against the British family or any other family since, there's no question as to what family I belong to.
与英国家庭或之后任何其他家庭相比，毫无疑问我属于哪个家庭。
He's funny, Jackie Mason. I'm not nuts about the show though. Me neither.
他很有趣，杰基·梅森。不过我不怎么喜欢这个秀。我也不。
Chicken soup? Oh yeah, it's good.
鸡汤？噢，是啊，不错。
I got news for you.
我有消息告诉你。
But he's not Jackie Mason.
但他不是杰基·梅森。
I don't like him and--
我不喜欢他，而且——
Jackie Mason is--
杰基·梅森是——
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the radio show Wiretap on the CBC and the author of the book Ladies And Gentlemen, The Bible!
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是加拿大广播公司《窃听》广播节目的主持人，也是《女士们先生们，圣经！》一书的作者。
[MUSIC - "YOU TALK TO MUCH" BY RUN-DMC]
[音乐 - 跑-DMC的《你们话太多》]
Act  Two, The Kids Stay In The Picture. If children ran Hollywood, what sort of films would they make? Well, because of video cameras, we can actually answer that question. There are 11-year-old auteurs. When he was a little kid, Darren Stein organized the kids on a little suburban cul-de-sac where he lived in Encino, California to make movies. They made dozens of films. They shot all the time, over the course of years. Darren says that he remembers wanting to get control of the video camera and make a movie from the moment that his dad first brought a camera home. He was seven years old, and he quickly invented a film for everyone to do.
第二幕，孩子们留在画面里。如果孩子们管理好莱坞，他们会制作什么样的电影？好吧，因为有摄像机，我们实际上可以回答这个问题。这有 11 岁的小导演。当他还是个小孩子时，达伦·斯坦组织了他住在加州恩西诺小郊区尽头的小区里的孩子们制作电影。他们制作了几十部影片。他们一直都在拍，历经多年。达伦说，他记得从他爸爸第一次带回家摄像机的那一刻起，他就想控制摄像机并制作一部电影。他当时七岁，很快就发明了一部电影让大家一起演。
It was called Crazy News. And it was basically a newscast that was supposed to be crazy. And my dad was filming it, because at the time, I was seven or eight years old. So I wasn't allowed, nor could I probably hold the camera.
它叫《疯狂新闻》。基本上是一档应该很疯狂的新闻广播。我爸爸在拍，因为那时我才七八岁。所以我没被允许，大概也没法拿住摄像机。
And you're in a rec room or something.
然后你们在娱乐室之类的地方。
Yeah. We're in the den of the house. We're sitting on the couches. I had my neighborhood kids in a thing. It was me, and my next-door neighbor, Justin Satinover, and his sister, Lisa Satinover. My brother, Evan. Evan was probably five. He's three years younger than me. He's this tiny little kid wearing a little Batman shirt. And it begins with the camera on my brother, and he says:
是的。我们在家里的书房。我们坐在沙发上。我把邻居家的孩子叫来一起拍。有我、隔壁邻居贾斯汀·萨蒂诺弗和他的妹妹丽莎·萨蒂诺弗。还有我弟弟埃文。埃文大概五岁。他比我小三岁。他是个穿着蝙蝠侠小衬衫的小不点。视频开头摄像机对着我弟弟，他说：
[GIGGLING] Hello, ladies and gentlemen.
[咯咯笑] 大家好，女士们先生们。
Stop. Stop.
停。停。
And first of all, Evan couldn't get his line right, so that took seven or eight times, which was incredibly frustrating to me. Because I was very serious about these things.
首先，埃文台词说不对，那用了七八次，这让我感到非常沮丧。因为我对待这些事情非常严肃。
[GIGGLING] Hello, ladies and gentlemen. This-- I forgot.
[咯咯笑] 大家好，女士们先生们。这个——我忘了。
I was so frustrated.
我太沮丧了。
Forget it. Stop it.
算了。停下。
Now say it, Evan.
现在说，埃文。
No. I don't want this, daddy.
不。我不要这样，爸爸。
Hello, everybody. This is Crazy News. And now weather.
大家好。这是《疯狂新闻》。现在是天气预报。
And then it goes to me. And finally, I'm thrilled because I get to talk.
然后轮到我。最后，我很激动，因为轮到我说话了。
Hello, my name is Darren Stein from Crazy News. Now, in Arizona, it is so cold, it is snowing. Can you believe that? It's hot in Arizona.
你好，我是来自《疯狂新闻》的达伦·斯坦。现在，在亚利桑那州，天气太冷了，正在下雪。你相信吗？亚利桑那州天气很热。
So I was going on and on And I was saying this and that, and then the camera drifts away from me to this girl, Lisa. And she's sort of staring at the camera, looking at herself on TV, happy in that moment to have it on her. And I just flipped out because it wasn't the way I had planned it.
所以我一直在讲个不停，我在说这个那个，然后摄像机从我身上移到了这个叫丽莎的女孩身上。她正盯着摄像机看，在电视上看着自己，那一刻很高兴能出镜。我立刻就炸毛了，因为这和我计划的不一样。
I'm not doing it. Forget it, God dang it.
我不演了。算了，该死的。
Come on.
快点。
Do it over.
重来。
No.
不。
I should have said the weather and the camera stayed on me for my whole spiel. And then I would have announced either Lisa or Justin, and the camera would have gone to them. And Justin would do sports, and Lisa would do entertainment, like a real newscast.
我应该说完天气，摄像机全程对着我。然后我会介绍丽莎或贾斯汀，摄像机才会切过去。贾斯汀会做体育，丽莎会做娱乐，像真正的新闻节目一样。
When you watch this as an adult, whose side are you on? Because I have to say, everybody else in the room is just trying to have fun, and there you are, baby Cecil B. DeMille.
当你成年后看这段视频时，你站在哪一边？因为我得说，房间里其他每个人都在试图找乐子，而你却像个婴儿版的塞西尔·B·戴米尔。
I feel bad for my parents, more than anything. And the other kids. A little embarrassing too.
比起其他任何事，我更替我的父母感到难过。还有其他孩子。也挺尴尬的。
So at some point, you actually get your hands on the movie camera, when you're 10 or 11. And you start filming all the time, right?
所以到了某个阶段，你在 10 或 11 岁时真的拿到了摄像机。然后你开始一直拍，对吧？
Yeah, just filming stuff. When my parents would go out, we were trapped on this cul-de-sac in the hills of Encino. So we were sort of shipwrecked up there. And we had nothing else to do. It was sort of like, what do we do now? Let's make a movie. Mark Entous's backyard was this big, verdant, green lawn. And we'd go back there for the jungle films or for the adventure, Indiana Jones -type movies. Michael's house-- or in front of it, there was this canyon that was really dry. So we'd use that for the Vietnam movies.
是的，只是随便拍拍。当我父母出门时，我们被困在恩西诺山丘这个死胡同里。所以我们有点像在那儿遇难了。我们没别的事可做。就好像，现在我们要干什么？让我们拍部电影吧。马克·恩图斯的后院有片大大的、青翠的草坪。我们会去那儿拍丛林电影，或者冒险电影，印第安纳·琼斯风格的。迈克尔家——或者在他家前面，有个非常干燥的峡谷。所以我们用那儿拍越南战争电影。
Hold your breath, guys. It's a mine.
屏住呼吸，伙计们。那是地雷。
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
They did a Holocaust film when he was 11. They did a film about the day after a nuclear war. In these early films, the high concepts were just excuses so that the main characters can run around and try to kill each other. There are a lot of gratuitous ninja moves. There's the prerequisite ketchup-as-gore. Because Darren was three years older than anybody on the street, it was easy for him to call the shots.
他在 11 岁时拍过一部大屠杀电影。他们拍过一部关于核战后的电影。在这些早期影片中，崇高的理念只是为了让主角们可以跑来跑去并试图互相残杀。里面有很多无缘无故的忍者动作。有必不可少的番茄酱当作血浆。因为达伦比街上任何人都要大三岁，他发号施令很容易。
Darren always seemed very powerful.
达伦看起来总是很有权力。
This is Adam Schell, who lived on the cul-de-sac and appears in lots of the movies.
这是亚当·谢尔，他住在死胡同里，在很多电影中都有出镜。
Darren was always the one that everybody looked up to. Basically, whatever Darren said, went.
达伦一直是每个人都仰望的人。基本上，达伦说什么就是什么。
Action. Camera rolling. Cut.
开始。摄像机开动。停。
And what would it mean to be in one of these films? What would it mean to get a big part in one of these films?
那么成为这些电影的一部分意味着什么？在这些电影里得到一个大角色意味着什么？
To me, it was the world. To me, it meant everything. It was the most exciting, the most cool thing that we did as kids.
对我来说，那就是全世界。对我来说，那意味着一切。这是我们小时候做的最令人兴奋、最酷的事情。
And would kids vie for parts in the films?
孩子们会争夺电影里的角色吗？
Totally. I would actually offer the part to one kid, and then decide I didn't want him anymore, offer it to somebody else, and create little dramas behind the scenes.
完全会。我实际上会把角色给一个孩子，然后决定我不想要他了，再给别人，在幕后制造些小冲突。
As we got older, I think when Darren was in high school and he made a couple of films through his high school drama program, there was more of an auditioning process. The first film he made there was Song From Below . I remember auditioning for that. And I remember Darren giving me the part for that film. And I remember I just felt so cool. And then I remember when he took it away from me, and he gave it to Michael. And I don't remember what his reasoning for it was. In fact, I think he didn't have a specific reasoning. I think he was just like, oh, I'm just going to take it away from you and give it to Michael because I can. And I remember going home and sitting on my bed and crying. It was just utter, crushing defeat.
随着我们长大，我想当达伦上高中，通过他的高中戏剧节目制作了几部电影时，选角过程就更多了。他拍的第一部电影是《底层的歌》。我记得为那部戏试镜。我记得达伦给了我那个角色。然后我记得当他收回它，把它给迈克尔时。我不记得他当时给出的理由是什么。事实上，我觉得他根本没有具体的理由。我觉得他只是觉得，噢，我就是要从你手里拿走给迈克尔，因为我可以。我记得回家坐在床上哭。那简直是彻底的、压倒性的失败。
You know what it's like, though? It's like, a little kid decides to become a director. And then, not only do they have films to show for it, but their personality becomes like a movie director gone power crazy.
你知道那是什么感觉吗？就像一个小孩子决定成为导演。然后，他们不仅有可以展示的电影，而且他们的个性变得像一个权力疯狂的电影导演。
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. And it was a total miniature Hollywood. That's what it was like on our street. And Darren loved that power, and he maintained it the entire time. And he had the power to make you a star, and he had the power to crush you. And the fact that we wanted it so bad, as well--
是啊。是啊，完全是。这就像一个微缩的好莱坞。在我们那条街上就是这样。达伦喜欢那种权力，他全程掌控着。他有能力让你成为明星，也有能力摧毁你。而且我们渴望得到这个，同样——
--is also so like the real Hollywood.
——也太像真正的好莱坞了。
Exactly. It's just like the real Hollywood.
没错。这就像真正的好莱坞。
When you look back on that, do you feel a little embarrassed?
当你回首往事时，你会觉得有点尴尬吗？
I feel totally embarrassed about that. It was just, I guess, my way of controlling the situation and having fun. And kids are cruel. It was part of that power thing.
我对此完全感到尴尬。我想那只是我控制局面和找乐子的方式。而且孩子们很残忍。那是那种权力游戏的一部分。
As soon as that camera came out, everybody just crumbled in front of it and did whatever Darren behind the camera ordered us to do. There's some really intense videos that we made as kids.
摄像机一拿出来，每个人就在它面前瘫倒，做任何达伦在摄像机后面命令我们做的事情。我们小时候制作的一些视频真的很激烈。
What are you thinking about?
你在想什么？
Well, I mean, I think there's some-- like the Gay as a Whistle film, for example, where Darren puts Allen, who is now openly gay, but at the time, Allen probably knew somewhere in his head, but he wasn't admitting it to the world. And Darren sees this thing in Allen, and maybe it's because they had some sort of underlying communication between the two of them. But he takes that, and he makes a movie about it, and he exploits this thing about Allen that he didn't want anybody in the world to know.
好吧，我的意思是，我想有些——比如《像哨子一样直》那部电影，达伦让艾伦出镜，他现在是公开的同性恋，但在当时，艾伦可能潜意识里知道，但他并没有向世界承认。达伦看到了艾伦身上的这一点，也许是因为他们俩之间有什么潜在的交流。但他拿走这一点，拍了一部关于它的电影，他利用了艾伦不想让世界上任何人知道的事。
I think I was 12 years old when I made that film. Gay as a Whistle is about a gay guy who has a coin in this little jewelry case. And when he shows you the coin, you turn gay basically. And this is back in the '80s when aerobics was big, and so our moms all wore leotards. And I thought, how cool would it be to put Allen in a leotard?
我想我拍那部电影时才 12 岁。《像哨子一样直》是关于一个同性恋家伙，他有一个小首饰盒里的硬币。当你给你看硬币时，你基本上就会变成同性恋。那还是 80 年代，健美操很流行，所以我们的妈妈们都穿紧身连衣裤。我想，让艾伦穿上紧身连衣裤会有多酷？
Right. So he's wearing this leotard with lip marks all over it.
对。所以他穿着这件上面印满唇印的紧身连衣裤。
Exactly. And the film starts out with him sitting in a rocking chair, looking very gay, rocking back and forth. And the camera is right on him. And he turns in to the camera and goes, "Hi, my name is Ramon. And I've got a little secret for you. I'm as gay as a whistle."
没错。电影开头他坐在摇椅上，看起来非常同性恋，摇来摇去。摄像机正对着他。他转向摄像机说，“嗨，我叫拉蒙。我有个小秘密要告诉你。我像哨子一样直。”
Hi, my name is Ramon. And I've got a little secret for you. I'm as gay as a whistle. I've got this coin here that will make anyone gay when they look at it. Here comes the football team.
嗨，我叫拉蒙。我有个小秘密要告诉你。我像哨子一样直。我有枚硬币在这里，当任何人看它时都会变同性恋。足球队来了。
Hey, great scrimmage, wasn't that?
嘿，刚才的混战很棒，不是吗？
And basically, we have the football team coming up, and the baseball coach coming up. And at first, they see the gay guy, and they're like, ew, it's the gay guy. Let's beat him up. And then he opens the coin. And they're like, "Ooh, I'm gay."
基本上，我们有足球队走过来，棒球教练走过来。起初，他们看到那个同性恋家伙，反应是，咦，是那个同性恋家伙。我们揍他一顿吧。然后他打开了硬币。他们就变成了，“噢，我是同性恋。”
Oh, it's the gay guy. Shouldn't we beat him up?
噢，是那个同性恋家伙。我们不应该揍他一顿吗？
Yeah, come on.
是啊，快点。
Wait. Look at my coin.
等一下。看看我的硬币。
Oh my God. Roses, bouquets, flowers. Oh, my God. Roses.
噢，天哪。玫瑰，花束，鲜花。噢，天哪。玫瑰。
One of the things I think is so funny about Gay as a Whistle is that as soon as the boys are turned into gay, the way that they express it is that they yell the words, "Roses."
我觉得《像哨子一样直》里最滑稽的事情之一就是，男孩们一变成同性恋，他们表达的方式就是大喊“玫瑰”这个词。
Gay is about roses, for some reason.
同性恋不知为何就成了玫瑰。
And did you feel like the film was about you? Or was it even that conscious?
你觉得那部电影是在讲你吗？或者它甚至是有意识的吗？
It was not that conscious.
那不是有意识的。
Did you think of yourself as gay back then?
你那时觉得自己是同性恋吗？
No, I wouldn't admit that I was. But I think I knew I was. But I would never, ever admit it to anyone.
不，我才不会承认。但我认为我知道。但我绝不会向任何人承认。
Is this the end of the world? What would happen if this happened to the president? Will the world turn out gay? Stay tuned next week when Darren Stein Productions present:
这是世界末日吗？如果这发生在总统身上会怎样？世界会变成同性恋吗？下周请继续关注，达伦·斯坦制片公司呈献：
Gay as a Whistle.
《像哨子一样直》。
What weird about it is that it's simultaneously gay-loving and homophobic at the same time.
奇怪的是它同时既拥护同性恋又恐同。
Well, because that's how kids are. I think that's how young gay kids are because you love yourself, but you hate yourself at the same time. What better way not to be gay than to make fun of them and to demonize them?
好吧，因为小孩子就是这样。我认为年轻的同性恋孩子就是这样，因为你爱自己，但同时又恨自己。还有什么比嘲笑他们、妖魔化他们更能让自己不成为同性恋的方法呢？
I remember-- it's actually funny. If you watch it, at the very end, Evan and I come up. We're on the football team. And Allen turns us gay with the thing, and then we skip off together. And I remember you see me grab Evan and hug him. And I remember everybody else teasing me about that constantly, being like, oh, you must be gay because look what you did there. Look what you did.
我记得——其实挺好笑的。如果你看它，最后埃文和我出现。我们是足球队的。艾伦用那东西把我们变成了同性恋，然后我们一起跳着跑开了。我记得你看到我抓住埃文并拥抱他。我记得其他人不断拿这事取笑我，比如，噢，你肯定是同性恋，看你刚才做了什么。看你做了什么。
And to me, I was like, I'm playing the part. That's what I was supposed to do.
对我来说，我当时想的是，我是在演戏。我本就该那么做。
I am an actor.
我是一个演员。
Exactly. I'm an actor. I'm playing the part. I'm getting into this role. And I don't think there was ever a moment when somebody wasn't being picked on, whether it was Michael, me, Evan, Mark.
没错。我是一个演员。我在演戏。我正在进入这个角色。我不认为有任何时候没人被欺负，无论是迈克尔、我、埃文还是马克。
I noticed you don't list Darren in that little list.
我注意到你没把达伦列在那份名单里。
Darren was never picked on. Darren was always the one doing the picking. Because if he started picking on somebody else, then he was safe.
达伦从来没被欺负过。达伦总是那个欺负人的人。因为如果他开始欺负别人，那么他就安全了。
You also made a musical called I Have No Friends .
你还拍了一部叫《我没有朋友》的音乐剧。
Yeah. I went to an all boys junior high/high school. And these kids just did not know what to make of me. And I got made fun of a lot.
是的。我上了一所全男生的初中/高中。这些孩子根本不知道拿我怎么办。我经常被嘲笑。
And you had no friends?
你没有朋友？
You have to understand something. When I was in sixth grade at this public school, I was president of my class. I was just used to being really loved by people and popular. And so suddenly, I wasn't anymore.
你得理解一件事。我在公立学校上六年级时，我是班长。我习惯了被大家喜爱和欢迎。所以突然间，我不再是了。
Right, and everybody hit adolescence. And you're the gay-seeming kid.
对，大家进入了青春期。而你是那个看起来像同性恋的孩子。
Yeah, and I was completely gay and awkward and chunky and acne, and it was the whole-- and so the street was completely my escape from that all. It was my insulated world where I called the shots. But I Have No Friends was never consciously about me when I made that.
是啊，我完全是个同性恋，笨拙、胖乎乎、长痘痘，那是整个——所以那条街完全是我逃避这一切的出口。那是我与世隔绝的世界，我说了算。《我没有朋友》在我制作它时，从来没想过是关于我自己的。
[SINGING] I have no friends. Every day at school I sit alone at lunch. I have no friends.
[唱歌] 我没有朋友。每天在学校吃午饭我都独自坐着。我没有朋友。
Darren didn't have friends. I think, as long as I can remember, Darren maybe had three or four friends throughout most of high school and junior high.
达伦没有朋友。我认为，只要我记得，达伦在整个高中和初中期间可能只有三四个朋友。
Outside the group, you mean.
我是指在这个群体之外。
Yeah, outside the group.
是啊，在这个群体之外。
[SINGING] I have no friends. I have no friends.
[唱歌] 我没有朋友。我没有朋友。
You've, as an adult, made two feature films, one called Jawbreaker, one called Sparkler. Did you feel that you had more freedom to express yourself when you were 11 and 12 making movies?
你成年后制作了两部长片，一部叫《烂苹果》，一部叫《火花塞》。当你 11、12 岁拍电影时，你觉得表达自己的自由度更大吗？
Unquestionably. When you're a kid, it comes straight from your id onto the film.
毫无疑问。当你是个孩子时，它直接从你的本我流露到影片中。
Darren Stein and Adam Schell have collected their own movies and created a documentary about them called Put the Camera On Me . It's available on DVD.
达伦·斯坦和亚当·谢尔收集了他们自己的电影，并创作了一部关于它们的纪录片叫《把摄像机对准我》。它可以在 DVD 上买到。
Coming up, when America just leaves the camera running, what does it see? And a Hollywood teen movie plot comes to a home movie. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，当美国人只是让摄像机一直开着，它会看到什么？一个好莱坞青春片情节进入了家庭录像。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, home movies and the stories they tell, intentionally and unintentionally. We've arrived at Act Three of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是《家庭录像》，以及它们有意或无意讲述的故事。我们进入了节目的第三幕。
Back when home movies were actually movies, real movies on real film, they were expensive to make. The cameras were hard to use. You actually had to know how to work a camera pretty well. You'd run out of film in just three minutes. So most people really did restrict themselves to filming celebrations, babies, and vacations. But now that video cameras and videotape are so cheap, relatively speaking, people just leave the camera running for hours. And nobody knows this better than the producers of America's Funniest Home Videos, which has an archive of half a million video clips.
回到家庭录像是真正的电影、胶片上真正的电影的时代，制作它们很昂贵。摄像机很难用。你实际上必须相当了解怎么操作摄像机。你三分钟内胶片就用完了。所以大多数人确实限制自己只拍摄庆典、婴儿和假期。但现在摄像机和录像带如此便宜，相对而言，人们只是让摄像机开着好几个小时。没有人比《全美最有趣家庭录像》的制作人更了解这一点，它拥有 50 万个视频片段的档案。
Todd Thicke is the co-executive producer of the show. Trace Beaulieu and Mike Palleschi have been writers on the program. They each watch hundreds of home video clips each week. They say that they have seen video where people just set up a tripod and film themselves watching TV. They have no idea why.
托德·瑟克是该节目的联合执行制片人。特蕾斯·博利厄和迈克·帕莱斯基一直是节目的编剧。他们每个人每周观看数百个家庭视频片段。他们说，他们见过人们架起三脚架拍摄自己看电视的视频。他们根本不知道为什么。
A lot of kids on stage.
舞台上有很多孩子。
People golfing because they want to get their swing down. So that's why we have a million people losing their drivers. And we also see a Little League baseball game. We get a lot of the kid walking off the field saying, I gotta go pee, Mommy, and stuff like that.
人们打高尔夫球因为他们想练好挥杆。所以这就是为什么我们有一百万人在丢失发球杆。我们也看到过小联盟棒球赛。我们看到很多孩子走出赛场说，我要去嘘嘘，妈妈，之类的东西。
Then kids sleeping on toilets. Parents universally think their child sleeping on the toilet is funny.
然后是孩子们在马桶上睡觉。父母普遍认为自己的孩子在马桶上睡觉很有趣。
And when somebody has a video of, for example-- I've seen videos on the show of somebody trying to change a lightbulb and then a mishap happening. How do you explain the fact that they're filming the changing of a light bulb?
当有人拥有例如——我在节目中看过有人试图换灯泡然后发生事故的视频。你如何解释他们拍摄换灯泡这件事？
They don't lead very interesting lives? That's a highlight? Trace, why did they tape themselves changing a lightbulb?
他们过得并不有趣？那是亮点？特蕾斯，他们为什么拍自己换灯泡？
Because they don't have kids and their cat is boring.
因为他们没有孩子，而且他们的猫很无聊。
And they got a camera.
而且他们有摄像机。
And is it your impression that there are a lot of people out there filming all the time?
你觉得外面有很多人一直在拍摄吗？
I think that that is fairly prevalent out there. I think if people have cameras, they're shooting stuff. We sometimes say, what are they shooting here? What did they have the camera set up for?
我认为这种情况相当普遍。我觉得如果人们有摄像机，他们就在拍东西。我们有时会说，他们在这儿拍什么呢？他们架起摄像机是为了什么？
Sometimes we've seen people videotaping their sheetrocking. It's like, why are they taping this? And then someone will fall through a ceiling. But you see one, and you go, OK, that's an anomaly. And then you see 20 guys taping themselves sheetrocking.
有时我们看到人们拍摄他们装石膏板的过程。就像，他们为什么拍这个？然后有人会从天花板上掉下来。但你看到一个，你会想，好吧，那是异常情况。然后你看到 20 个人拍摄自己装石膏板。
I think you tape what you got. If that's your life and that's what you do-- if you're Cameron Diaz, you're at a premier. And if you're sheetrocking--
我觉得你拍你有的东西。如果那是你的生活，那是你做的事——如果你是卡梅隆·迪亚兹，你在首映礼上。如果你是在装石膏板——
There was a guy, yesterday, pulling his cactus out alongside of the pool. And then he fell into the pool. We thought, did he set that up?
昨天有个家伙在泳池边拔仙人掌。然后他掉进了泳池。我们心想，那是他们安排好的吗？
Set up.
安排好的。
Or did they really say, we've got to go film Dad taking the cactus out?
还是他们真的说，我们得去拍爸爸拔仙人掌？
It was a set up. We can spot the setups all the time.
那是安排好的。我们总能一眼看穿这些安排。
Aha. Now, that's very interesting. What's the tip off that it's a set up? What are the tricks? How can you tell?
啊哈。那太有趣了。安排的提示是什么？有什么技巧？你怎么看出来的？
Camera placement is a big tip off. They have the shot. Normally, they don't get the shot. The camera's moving around, and they miss the birthday cake burning someone.
摄像机位置是个大提示。他们得到了镜头。通常，他们拍不到。摄像机到处晃，他们错过了生日蛋糕烧到人的镜头。
Yeah. Usually when the moment happens, when you're taping something and something happens, you drop the camera, just for a split second or something, or you take your eye off it, and the shot jerks away. But if you hold that shot steady, there was no surprise to you.
是啊。通常当时刻发生时，当你拍东西发生什么事情时，你会扔掉摄像机，哪怕只是一瞬间，或者你视线离开了它，镜头就会猛地移开。但如果你能保持那个镜头稳定，说明这事对你来说并不意外。
I never would have thought of that.
我从来没想过这一点。
I think it's an involuntary reaction. But not enough to help anyone.
我认为这是一种非自愿反应。但不足以帮助任何人。
Does everybody's family seem the same, when you watch one of these videos after another?
当你一个接一个看这些视频时，每个家庭看起来都一样吗？
Yes and no. I mean, you see at the weddings when they pass the camera around and the microphone, and people say things into the camera, we find rich, poor, black, or white, there's always the person who puts the microphone up to their ear like a telephone. Or we had an old lady take the microphone and said, I'll have the chicken. It seems like, no matter what you are, there's always that person at your wedding.
是也不是。我是说，你看婚礼时他们传递摄像机和麦克风，人们对着摄像机说话，我们发现无论是富人、穷人、黑人还是白人，总有那个人像打电话一样把麦克风贴在耳朵边。或者我们有位老太太接过麦克风说，我要吃鸡肉。看起来无论你是谁，婚礼上总有那个人。
Who will make that joke.
谁会开那个玩笑。
And every wedding has that one guy who really can't dance.
而且每个婚礼都有那个确实不会跳舞的家伙。
But around the kitchen and the den when they're hanging out with the kids playing on the floor, everybody seems like, it's a nice country out there. Doesn't most of it seem-- in people's homes?
但在厨房和书房，当他们和在地上玩耍的孩子们待在一起时，每个人看起来都像，那是个美好的国家。大部分看起来不都像——在人们家里吗？
Do you guys shoot home videos?
你们拍家庭录像吗？
I don't. But I did just get engaged. And I've seen more weddings, I think, than anybody. And my fiance couldn't understand why I was so nervous. And I had to explain to her, well, after two years of watching people catch on fire, throw up at the altar, pass out, and all these horrible things, people letting the doves go, and they poop on the bride, I was little squeamish about a wedding in general.
我不拍。但我刚订婚。我觉得我看过的婚礼比任何人都多。我未婚妻不明白为什么我那么紧张。我不得不向她解释，好吧，看了两年人们着火、在祭坛上呕吐、昏倒，以及所有这些可怕的事情，人们放走鸽子，它们却拉在新娘身上，我对一般婚礼有点敏感。
Right. A wedding just seems like a series of possible accidents waiting to happen.
对。婚礼看起来就像一系列等待发生的事故。
Well, I've learned you don't to have open flame near the veils.
好吧，我学会了头纱附近不要有明火。
The father's pants.
父亲的裤子。
Yes, all the old men must have their belts securely fastened around their waists. And no comedy at the altar. We've seen a lot of guys who-- oh, I can't find the ring. And then the UPS guy will run in the front. They've made the most special moment of their life into a Lucy skit.
是的，所有的老男人都必须把皮带紧紧扣在腰上。祭坛上不要有喜剧。我们看过很多家伙——噢，我找不到戒指了。然后 UPS 的人会跑进前场。他们把自己一生中最特殊的时刻变成了露西的短剧。
Mike Palleschi, Todd Thicke, and Trace Beaulieu of America's Funniest Home Videos . You can watch that TV show on the ABC television network Sunday nights at 7:00, 6:00 Central. That was such an official-sounding thing to say on the radio. I've never said anything like that in my life.
迈克·帕莱斯基、托德·瑟克和《全美最有趣家庭录像》的特蕾斯·博利厄。你可以在美国广播公司电视网每周日晚上 7:00，中部时间 6:00 收看该电视节目。那在广播里听起来太官方了。我这辈子从来没说过那样的话。
Well, Act Four. The Cinema Of Upward Mobility. The plot line of a home movie is usually more home than movie. These are not usually, as you may gather, the most cinematic stories being told. When she was a teenager, Susan Burton tried to do something that you see many teenagers attempt in teen movies, and she actually pulled it off. As luck would have it, the effort was caught on video, and we offer it here as a kind of alternative to the Hollywood version of the story. Her family's videos, I should say, begin inauspiciously enough.
好吧，第四幕。向上流动的电影。家庭录像的情节通常是家庭多于电影。正如你们可能体会到的，这些通常不是最电影化的故事。当她还是青少年时，苏珊·伯顿试图做你在青少年电影中经常看到的许多青少年尝试的事情，而且她真的成功了。幸运的是，这段努力被视频拍了下来，我们把它作为该故事好莱坞版本的一种替代品放在这里。我应该说，她家庭的录像带开始得还算祥和。
My dad videotaped a lot of things, all the typical stuff. My little sister Betsy's preschool dance recital.
我爸爸录了很多东西，所有典型的玩意儿。我小妹妹贝齐的学前班舞蹈表演。
[SINGING] Rubber ducky, you're the one.
[唱歌] 橡皮鸭子，你就是那个。
My solo in the fourth grade spring choral concert.
我在四年级春季合唱音乐会上的独唱。
[SINGING] The hills are alive with the sound of music.
[唱歌] 群山因音乐之声而生机勃勃。
Birthday dinners.
生日晚餐。
[SINGING] Happy birthday dear Susan. Happy birthday to you.
[唱歌] 生日快乐，亲爱的苏珊。祝你生日快乐。
Holidays like Easter Sunday, when we hunted for eggs the Bunny hid on the first floor of our house.
像复活节星期天这样的节日，我们在房子的一楼寻找兔子藏起来的蛋。
I found one in the bathroom. You know what? I found one in the bathroom.
我在洗手间发现了一个。你知道吗？我在洗手间发现了一个。
Was it in the toilet?
它在马桶里吗？
No.
没有。
I just wanted to make sure you found an egg.
我只是想确保你找到了一个蛋。
I found an egg.
我找到了一个蛋。
Until two weeks ago, I hadn't watched these videos for years. When I put them in the VCR, I couldn't believe that the world could exist like this again, that it could just pop up like a stage set, my parents still married, all of us together in our old house.
直到两周前，我已经好多年没看这些录像了。当我把它们放进录像机时，我无法相信世界能再次这样存在，它可以像舞台布景一样突然冒出来，我的父母依然结婚，我们所有人依然聚在我们老房子里。
OK, why don't you guys all get next to Daddy? It's probably not good for me to be out in the dark, is it?
好的，为什么你们不都到爸爸身边去呢？我在黑暗中可能不太好，是吗？
No, it's fine.
不，没关系。
When I was little and planning on becoming famous, I always used to imagine that my house would be turned into a museum of my life, an exact reproduction of my seat at the dining room table, the order of the dolls in a row on my cedar chest, the Ramona book marked at the place I'd stopped before going to bed. Having these videos is like buying a ticket and opening our yellow front door and taking the tour.
小时候计划成名时，我总是想象我的家会变成我生活的博物馆，我餐桌座位的精确复制品，香柏木箱上娃娃的排列顺序，我在去睡觉前标记好的拉蒙娜书。拥有这些录像就像买了一张票，打开我们黄色的前门，开始参观。
When so much of your childhood is documented, there are going to be moments you wish had been left out. For me, that moment is an entire era, middle school. It begins with a hike up Baxter Mountain.
当你童年的很大一部分被记录下来时，总会有你希望被删掉的时刻。对我来说，那个时刻是一个完整的时代：初中。它始于一次爬巴克斯特山。
OK, you guys ready for another Baxter Mountain trip?
好的，你们准备好再去一次巴克斯特山了吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
OK.
好的。
Every summer, my mom, my dad, Betsy, and I climbed Baxter together. Baxter's a good hike for children.
每年夏天，我妈、我爸、贝齐和我一起爬巴克斯特山。巴克斯特山对于孩子来说是很好的远足地。
It's 1.1 miles.
它是 1.1 英里。
In this video, Betsy's seven years old. She's adorable. She skips up the trail. She searches the trees for the soft, white semicircles of fungus we break off and take home as souvenirs of the hike. She throws up her tiny arms and beams at my father with giant, brown eyes. She pipes up with little observations about nature.
在这段视频中，贝齐七岁。她很可爱。她在小径上蹦蹦跳跳。她寻找树上那些我们折下来带回家作为远足纪念品的柔软、白色的半圆形真菌。她举起瘦小的双臂，睁着棕色的大眼睛对着我父亲笑。她会观察自然并发表小小的评论。
Oh, these are roots. They go down into the ground. Let me see if I can find the taproot.
噢，这些是根。它们深入地下。让我看看能不能找到主根。
What is it called, Betsy?
那叫什么，贝齐？
The taproot.
主根。
Taproot?
主根？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
When the camera pans to me, it's a different story. Allow me to describe myself. I'm 11, almost 12. I'm wearing a rubber snake around my neck. My t-shirt has a row of teddy bears across the front. Each bear holds a balloon with a letter on it, and together they spell the word "stickers." It is difficult to see my eyes, which are masked by enormous round glasses. I look like an owl, like something from science. I look like what I was at the time, which is a nerd. I regale my family with nuggets from my repository of random nerd facts. When my sister wonders if there are killer bees on Baxter Mountain, I'm ready with the answer.
当摄像机扫向我时，故事就不同了。允许我描述一下我自己。我 11 岁，快 12 岁了。我脖子上戴着一条橡胶蛇。我的 T 恤前面有一排泰迪熊。每只熊拿着一个带有字母的气球，加在一起拼出“贴纸”这个词。很难看到我的眼睛，它们被巨大的圆眼镜遮住了。我看起来像只猫头鹰，像科学产物。我看起来像我当时的样子，即书呆子。我用我的随机书呆子事实库给家人讲段子。当妹妹想知道巴克斯特山上是否有杀人蜂时，我已经准备好了答案。
Are there killer bees around here?
这儿附近有杀人蜂吗？
Not last summer, but the summer before, I checked out a book at the library. And it was all about these killer bees who were killing people. And then when I got back home to Grand Rapids, I read a story in the paper, and it said that there's killer bees in South America, and they should be coming up here in about five years or something. And then it was 1983. So they should be coming up about 1988.
去年夏天没有，但前年夏天，我从图书馆借了一本书。全是关于这些杀死人的杀人蜂的。然后当我回到大急流城，我在报纸上读到一个故事，说南美有杀人蜂，它们大约五年后会来到这里。当时是 1983 年。所以它们应该会在 1988 年左右来到。
Not long after the hike up Baxter, I started seventh grade at a new school in my Michigan hometown, Central Middle School. I'd gone to my old school since I was three and loved it, and now that I was at Central Middle, I missed it like crazy. Longings for it would well up inside me every Thursday night, when the "Sometimes you want to go where everybody knows your name" song played before Cheers. But it wasn't long before everybody knew my name at Central Middle.
爬完巴克斯特山不久后，我在密歇根老家的一所新学校——中央初中开始了七年级。我从三岁起就一直在我的旧学校，很爱它，现在既然在中央初中，我疯狂地想念它。每到周四晚上，《干杯》剧集前播放那首“有时你想去每个人都知道你名字的地方”的歌时，思念之情就会在我心中汹涌。但没过多久，每个人都知道我在中央初中的名字了。
Around Halloween, we received our first report cards in homeroom. My homeroom teacher was Mr. Bixler. He taught earth science and had a fondness for puns. He liked to add fake names to the attendance slip, like Eileen Dover or Justin Case. Mr. Bixler shuffled through the pile of report cards on his desk. Suddenly he held one up to the light, as if verifying its authenticity. "Susie Burton," he said. "Five A's and two A pluses."
万圣节前后，我们在班主任课上收到了第一张成绩单。我的班主任是比克斯勒先生。他教地球科学，偏爱双关语。他喜欢在点名册上加假名字，比如艾琳·多佛或贾斯汀·凯斯。比克斯勒先生翻着桌上的一叠成绩单。突然他把一张举到光线下，好像在验证真实性。“苏西·伯顿，”他说，“五个 A，两个 A 加。”
The boy in our homeroom with Tourette's Syndrome let out a series of profanities and yelps. I wanted to flee, but my desk was surrounded. Kids were actually coming over to see my report card. "She even got an A in gym," one boy exclaimed.
我们班上有图雷特综合征的男孩发出了一连串亵渎和尖叫。我想逃跑，但我的课桌被围住了。孩子们真的走过来想看我的成绩单。“她甚至在体育课都得了 A，”一个男孩惊呼道。
I'd gotten off on the wrong foot at Central Middle. I had blind enthusiasm for spelling bees, book bowls, and science olympiads. I was the only girl in architectural drafting. My other elective was called brain teasers. I did the wrong things, and I looked the wrong way too. I had a short curly perm that hadn't come out the way it was supposed to, braces on my top and bottom teeth, and weird clothes like culottes. Everyone else at my school wore jeans and Reeboks. I wasn't allowed to wear either.
我在中央初中没开好头。我对比拼拼、书球和科学奥林匹克竞赛有着盲目的热情。我是建筑制图课上唯一的女孩。我的另一门选修课叫脑筋急转弯。我做了错误的事情，看起来也错了。我留着一个没烫好的卷发，上下牙带着牙套，穿着奇怪的衣服，比如裙裤。学校里其他人穿牛仔裤和锐步鞋。我不被允许穿这两样。
I'd had one pair of jeans in my life. I was permitted to get them for a school play. It was a one-act about a Michael Jackson concert, authored by a sixth grader at my old school. At the store, my mother pulled out dark blue Lee jeans with pinstripes. She said that my father might like this pair. They resembled business suit pants.
我这辈子只有一条牛仔裤。我是因为学校演出才被允许买的。那是一部关于迈克尔·杰克逊演唱会的一幕剧，由我旧学校的六年级学生创作。在商店里，我母亲拿出了带有细条纹的深蓝色李维斯牛仔裤。她说我父亲可能喜欢这一条。它们看起来像商务西裤。
My parents didn't understand. My father said that the boys in architectural drafting teased me because they liked me, all 27 of them. My mother said middle school didn't matter, that college was where you met your real friends. I needed to improve. I needed a manual. So I got a subscription to Seventeen magazine. Seventeen gave advice on a lot of things, like fresh face makeup that would let me shine through, and what I should do if I was better looking than my best friend. But before I could apply any of it at Central Middle, my parents got divorced. My grandfather said it was because we all read at the dinner table. I disagreed, but it didn't matter. We were selling our house, and my mom and Betsy and I were moving to Boulder, Colorado.
我父母不理解。我父亲说建筑制图课上的男孩嘲笑我，是因为他们喜欢我，那是全部 27 个男孩。我母亲说初中不重要，大学才是你结交真正朋友的地方。我需要改进。我需要一本手册。所以我订阅了《十七》杂志。十七杂志给出了很多事情的建议，比如能让我容光焕发的清新妆容，还有如果我比最好的朋友好看我该怎么办。但在我能在中央初中运用这些建议之前，我父母离婚了。外公说这是因为我们都在餐桌上读书。我不同意，但这不重要。我们要卖房子，我妈、贝齐和我搬到了科罗拉多州的博尔德。
My mother told me that she liked the idea of the west, of the frontier, of going there to make a fresh start. I liked the idea too. In the west, I would be popular. I would reinvent myself. Nobody would know that back in Michigan, I'd been a nerd. And best yet, I would attend Fairview High School, where a junior named Holly had just won the Seventeen cover model contest. I had the issue upstairs in my room, carefully filed in a little library of teendom.
母亲告诉我她喜欢西部的概念，边疆的概念，去那里重新开始。我也喜欢这个主意。在西部，我会很受欢迎。我会重塑自己。没人会知道我在密歇根曾经是个书呆子。最棒的是，我会去费尔维尤高中，那里的一名大三学生霍莉刚赢得了十七封面模特大赛。那期的杂志在我楼上房间里，小心地存放在我的少女小图书馆里。
By now, I'd been a student of popularity for two years. I did this with the intensity and seriousness with which I'd learned the migratory patterns of the killer bee. I had cassettes full of songs I'd taped off the radio. I'd accumulated the right clothes. I applied the scientific method to wardrobe selection. I typed up a list of my outfits on the Macintosh and posted it inside my closet. The list only applied to weekdays, and I did not deviate from the order. There were 16 outfits, so that there would always be an irregular beat built in, so that I wouldn't always wear Benetton rugby shirt on Mondays or the Guess overalls on Tuesday. The amazing thing is, the plan worked. We moved. I was popular. It was the fresh start any nerd dreams of. It was better than any article that had ever been in Seventeen.
那时候，我已经研究受欢迎度两年了。我带着学习杀人蜂迁徙模式的强度和严肃性来做这件事。我有存满从电台录下的歌曲的磁带。我攒够了合适的衣服。我将科学方法应用于衣橱选择。我在麦金塔电脑上打出我的服装清单，贴在衣柜里。该清单仅适用于工作日，而且我不偏离顺序。共有 16 套服装，所以总会有不规则的节奏，这样我就不会总是在周一穿贝纳通橄榄球衫，或者周二穿 Guess 背带裤。神奇的是，计划奏效了。我们搬家了。我很受欢迎。这是每个书呆子梦想的重新开始。它比十七杂志刊登过的任何文章都要棒。
I had a group of friends. We all sat together every day at lunch on our jean jackets in a circle in the front courtyard. We French braided each other's hair. We traded clothes. We had slumber parties. On weekdays, we'd often ride bikes until just before dark. One time, we were riding to the grocery store to get ingredients for chocolate chip cookies, and my shoe fell off in the crosswalk. It became a famous story. There was a famous story about me. The littlest things, things that probably didn't matter to anyone else, made me so happy. I saved any note anyone ever wrote to me in class. There was a girl in the house behind me named Shannon, and one night, we yelled to each other from our windows before we turned off our lights and went to bed. It had only happened that once, but I thought about it a lot. It was like something from a movie, like a dream life. And there's video documentation of this too.
我有一群朋友。我们每天午餐都坐在前院的牛仔夹克上围成一圈。我们给彼此编法式辫子。我们交换衣服。我们举办过夜派对。在工作日，我们经常骑自行车直到天黑前。有一次，我们正骑车去杂货店买做巧克力曲奇的配料，我的鞋在人行横道上掉了下来。这成了一个著名的故事。有一个关于我的著名故事。琐碎的事情，对别人可能无关紧要的事情，让我如此快乐。我保存了任何人在课上给我写的任何纸条。我家后面那栋房子的女孩叫香农，一天晚上，我们在关灯上床睡觉前从窗口互相大喊。那只发生过那一次，但我经常想它。就像电影里的东西，就像梦想生活。而且也有这段视频记录。
Susie? Hi. What should we do?
苏西？嗨。我们该干什么？
This is me on the telephone in Colorado.
这是在科罗拉多州电话里的我。
Well, I don't know. I heard a lot of people were going there, but remember what happened last night? OK, well, should we do that? Well, I don't know. OK, it's only, like, 7:30. So why don't we wait until, like, 8:00? And then we'll figure out something, OK? OK, should I call Lisa?
好吧，我不知道。我听说很多人都要去那里，但记得昨晚发生了什么吗？好吧，我们要那样做吗？好吧，我不知道。好吧，才 7:30 左右。所以为什么我们不等到 8:00 左右呢？然后我们会想出点什么的，好吗？好吧，我该打给丽莎吗？
In this video, I have long, straight, shiny blond hair. I have lip gloss, contact lenses, and perfect braceless teeth. I talk on the phone so much my mother has subscribed to call waiting.
在这段视频中，我留着长长、笔直、闪亮的金发。我有唇彩、隐形眼镜和完美的没牙套的牙齿。我打电话太多，母亲给我办了呼叫等待。
And then-- hold on a sec. Hello? Hello? Oh, gosh, my call waiting signal just messed up. OK, but anyway, you can come over, and we'll braid my hair. OK? And then we'll go down to Pearl Street, OK? OK, bye.
然后——等一下。喂？喂？噢，天哪，我的呼叫等待信号搞砸了。好吧，不管怎样，你可以过来，我们编编我的头发。好吗？然后我们去珍珠街，好吗？好吗，再见。
The rules of being popular seemed easy to me. Anybody could have done it. The main ones were, smile a lot. Wear good clothes. Giggle. Be a little ditzy. I started remembering to forget my lunch. But the main number one rule of being popular was, don't let anyone know you're smart. On US Government quizzes, I answered questions wrong on purpose.
受欢迎的规则对我来说似乎很简单。任何人都做得到。主要的几条是，多微笑。穿好看的衣服。咯咯笑。稍微傻点。我开始记得忘记带午餐。但受欢迎的头号规则是，不要让任何人知道你很聪明。在政府知识测验中，我故意答错问题。
But the notes we passed in language arts provided me with a real opportunity to shine. If my friend Joanna wrote, "Antigone sucks, and it's so cold. I wish we didn't have to walk home today," I would write back, "I know. I should of worn a sweater today." But I would spell "should've" like "should" and then the word "of," instead of the contraction for "should have." I'd continue, "Ms. C is totally on the rag today. She's bothering me alot." That's "alot," spelled as one word, no space.
但我们在语言艺术课上传的纸条给我提供了真正大放异彩的机会。如果我的朋友乔安娜写道，“安提戈涅烂透了，太冷了。我希望我们今天不用走回家，”我会回复，“我知道。我今天应该穿件毛衣的。”但我会把“should've”拼成“should”和“of”这两个词，而不是“should have”的缩写。我会继续，“C老师今天在闹情绪。她很烦我。”那是“alot”，拼成一个词，没空格。
Things were happening so naturally that I could almost convince myself that my life had always been this way. One Saturday night, a group of us went to see the movie, Can't Buy Me Love. The movie's about a nerd who decides that his senior year of high school, he's going to become popular at last. He pays the most beautiful girl in school to go out with him. It didn't even cross my mind to identify with the nerd. I was in so deep that I identified with the pretty blonde cheerleader.
事情发展得如此自然，以至于我几乎可以说服自己我的生活一直都是这样。一个周六晚上，我们一群人去看了电影《不能买爱》。电影是关于一个书呆子决定他在高三时要变得受欢迎。他付钱给学校最美丽的女孩带他出去。我甚至没想过把自己和书呆子对应起来。我陷得太深，以至于我认同了那个漂亮的金发啦啦队长。
Like sands through the hourglass, so are the days of our lives. I'm Susan Burton and
像沙漏里的沙子一样，这就是我们生活的日子。我是苏珊·伯顿，
Betsy Burton.
还有贝齐·伯顿。
And these are
而这些是
The days of our lives.
我们生活的日子。
These last two weeks, watching video of myself from those days, I saw something that wasn't clear to me at the time. Here's a tape Betsy and I made for our dad for Father's Day, two years after we moved to Boulder.
过去这两周，看着那个时代的我的视频，我看到了当时不清楚的事情。这是贝齐和我在我们搬到博尔德两年后，为父亲节制作的录像带。
We just wanted to make this video for you for Father's Day because we didn't want to get you a book, because we always do that. And this way you can look at us whenever you want to.
我们只是想为你父亲节制作这段视频，因为我们不想给你买书，因为我们总是那样。这样你任何时候想我们的时候都能看。
I look exactly right, studiously plain hair, silver bracelets, pretty clothes. But I'm still a nerd. Here I am, explaining the music of the young people to my dad.
我看起来完全正确，精心打扮的头发，银色手镯，漂亮的衣服。但我依然是个书呆子。这就是我，向爸爸解释年轻人的音乐。
And then, oh, Depeche Mode. Here's some Depeche Mode.
然后，噢，追随者乐队。这儿是一些追随者乐队。
I can't resist translating the name of the band.
我无法抗拒翻译乐队的名字。
Depeche means "hurried." Mode means "fashion." Hurried fashion. Or dispatch fashion. Yeah, it's dispatch. Because it's not sous depeche.
Depeche 的意思是“匆忙”。Mode 的意思是“时尚”。匆忙时尚。或者调度时尚。是的，是调度。因为不是 sous depeche。
In this video, what I see now is how hard I'm trying. I've blowdried my hair and matched my socks to my shorts, even though it's a summer morning and we're just staying home. I'm sarcastic in a way I know is meant to mimic two of my friends from school. I make a show of talking about driver's permits, even though I was terrified of the day I'd eventually get behind the wheel. The popular girl is in this video. There's proof that she exists. But it's clear that the killer bee girl is right inside her.
在这段视频中，我现在看到的是我努力了多少。我吹干了头发，把袜子和短裤搭好，即使那是个夏天的早晨，我们只是待在家里。我以一种我知道是为了模仿两个朋友的方式讽刺。我做出一副谈论驾驶执照的样子，即使我对以后坐在方向盘后面那一天的到来感到恐惧。那个受欢迎的女孩在这段视频里。有证据表明她存在。但显然，那个杀人蜂女孩就藏在她里面。
OK, I think that'll end my instructional video. As you can see, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] are better.
好的，我想我的教学视频到此结束。正如你所看到的，[听不清] 更好。
I didn't change that much.
我没改变那么多。
Susan Burton is a writer in New York City.
苏珊·伯顿是纽约市的作家。
[MUSIC - "NEW LIFE" BY DEPECHE MODE]
[音乐 - 追随者乐队的《新生活》]
Act Five, Just Shoot Me. We end our program today with this story from David Sedaris, a story asking the simple question, why even bother to make home movies?
第五幕，尽管拍吧。我们今天以大卫·塞达里斯的这个故事结束节目，这个故事问了一个简单的问题：为什么还要费心制作家庭录像呢？
It was the day before Thanksgiving, and my mother and I were at the Raleigh airport waiting for my sister Gretchen to return from Rhode Island. You could still smoke then, and so we sat beside the ashtray, passing the time as the plane rolled up to the gate. A young woman took a seat not far away, and when she pulled a camcorder from her knapsack, my mother groaned and prodded me with her elbow. "Oh, God, here we go."
那是感恩节的前一天，我和母亲在罗利机场等着我妹妹格雷琴从罗德岛回来。那时还可以抽烟，所以我们坐在烟灰缸旁边，打发时间，看着飞机滑向登机口。一个年轻女人坐在不远处，当她从背包里掏出一台摄像机时，母亲呻吟着，用胳膊肘顶了顶我。“噢，上帝，又来了。”
The camera was new and sleek, and as she aimed it towards a doorway, my mother covered the side of her face. "They shouldn't allow people to walk around with things like that," she said. "I mean, really. There should be a law." Had the young woman been carrying a loaded rifle, my mother might have brushed it off. But she hated having her picture taken. "Whoever she's waiting for might have it coming, but what about us poor nobodies caught in the crossfire? I don't want to be in some stranger's piss-poor movie," she said. "I don't even want to be in my own."
摄像机崭新且精致，当她把它对准门口时，母亲遮住了半张脸。“他们不该让人拿着那种东西到处走，”她说。“我是说，真的。应该有条法律。”如果那个年轻女人拿着一把上膛的步枪，母亲可能还会不以为意。但她讨厌被人拍照。“不管她在等谁，那是她的事，但我们这些无辜的过路人被困在交火中又算什么？我不想出现在某个陌生人的烂电影里，”她说。“我甚至不想出现在我自己的电影里。”
The young woman overheard and looked our way with an expression reading, "Who would want to videotape you?" I smiled, and she left her seat to stand against a column.
那个年轻女人听到了，向我们这边看了一眼，表情写着，“谁想拍你啊？”我笑了，她离开座位站在柱子旁。
"Why do people need to get everything on film?" my mother asked. "Are they that afraid they're going to forget something? And why do it here? Can't it at least wait for the parking lot?" The exit door opened, and passengers stepped out into the terminal. The young woman started filming, and my mother scowled as complete strangers waved into the camera. We were well out of range, but still she kept her hand to the side of her face, looking as though she were talking about the person seated next to her.
“为什么人们需要把一切都拍下来？”母亲问道。“他们真的那么害怕会忘记什么吗？而且为什么要在这儿拍？难道不能至少等到停车场吗？”出口打开了，乘客们走进候机楼。年轻女人开始拍摄，母亲皱着眉头，看着完全的陌生人对着摄像机挥手。我们离得够远，但她仍然捂着脸，看起来好像在和旁边座位上的人说话。
"Now, this is just ridiculous," she said. "I mean, what? Do you honestly think anyone's going to watch a thing like this? What's the point in making a movie when all anyone is doing is stepping off a damn airplane? It's not like it hasn't been done. It's not like there are any surprises here, so why bother with the $800 camera?"
“现在，这太荒谬了，”她说。“我是说，什么？你真的以为有人会看这种东西吗？拍电影的意义是什么，当所有人做的只是走下该死的飞机？又不是没拍过。这里面又没什么惊喜，所以为什么要费心用那个 800 美元的摄像机呢？”
My sister Gretchen stepped into the terminal and wondered why her mother was covering her face. "Do you have a toothache?" she asked. "Did somebody slap you?"
我妹妹格雷琴走进候机楼，纳闷母亲为什么捂着脸。“你牙疼吗？”她问。“有人打你了吗？”
There were more video cameras awaiting us at the baggage claim. A grown man filmed a toddler pounding against the side of a suitcase. A teenage boy shot his father hoisting a golf bag. "I've got to get out of here," my mother said. And then she went outside to wait in the car.
行李领取处有更多的摄像机在等着我们。一个成年男人拍着一个幼儿拍打手提箱侧面。一个少年拍摄他父亲搬运高尔夫球包。“我得离开这儿，”母亲说。然后她走到外面在车里等着。
Once, while at the beach, my father borrowed a movie camera and spent the afternoon following us around. We were young then and excited by the thought of watching ourselves projected onto a bed sheet. He shot us swimming and eating and piling on top of our mother who had tried in vain to escape. "This is going to be good," he said. "Come on, now. Pin her down, so I can get a good shot of her face."
曾经有一次在海滩，父亲借了一台电影摄像机，花了一下午时间跟着我们。那时我们还小，想到能看着自己被投射在床单上感到兴奋。他拍我们游泳、吃饭、扑向试图逃跑却徒劳的母亲。“这会很有趣，”他说。“来吧，现在。按住她，这样我就能拍到她脸部的特写。”
My sister Lisa would later suggest that there had been no film in the camera, but I don't think our father had it in him to be that cruel. Most likely, he set it aside, meaning to have it developed, but never quite finding the time. Either that or our mother got to it first. She was good at destroying film.
我妹妹丽莎后来暗示摄像机里根本没有胶片，但我认为父亲没那么残忍。很可能，他把它放在一边，打算去冲洗，但一直没腾出时间。要不就是母亲先动了手。她很擅长销毁胶片。
After she died, we took turns holding her various belongings to our noses. Mom's coat, Mom's washcloth, Mom's pillow. This is what people do when they're left with such paltry iconography. They smell things, continuing long after the scent has faded, and it feels silly to stand in the living room sniffing your mother's hairbrush. She'd been dead for three years when my aunt sent a home movie she'd transferred to videotape. This was film shot in the mid-'70s, when she and my uncle had gone with our parents to the Virgin Islands.
她去世后，我们轮流把她的各种遗物凑近鼻子闻。妈妈的外套，妈妈的洗脸巾，妈妈的枕头。当人们剩下这些寒酸的肖像画时就是这样。他们嗅着东西，一直持续到气味散去很久之后，站在客厅里嗅母亲的发梳确实显得很傻。她去世三年后，阿姨寄来了一盘她转录到录像带上的家庭录像。那是 70 年代中期拍摄的，那时她和叔叔和我父母去了维尔京群岛。
My sisters and I put the tape into the VCR and watched as my father silently pleaded with a locked door. We witnessed our aunt and uncle strolling white beaches and merrily waving from the deck of a boat. It wasn't until the end that we finally saw our mother and then only briefly. Whoever shot the footage had caught her unaware, walking out the door of a restaurant and slowly moving into the sun. It was such a small thing, our mother snapping shut her purse and putting one foot in front of the other, but it seemed to us like a miracle, like the way the movies must have seemed when they were very first invented.
我和姐妹们把录像带放进录像机，看着父亲默默地向一扇锁着的门祈求。我们目睹了阿姨和叔叔漫步在白色海滩上，在船甲板上欢快地挥手。直到最后，我们才终于看到了母亲，而且只有短暂的一刻。不管是谁拍摄的，拍到了她不知情的样子，正走出餐厅的门，缓慢地步入阳光中。那是多么小的一件事，母亲合上钱包，一步接着一步，但在我们看来就像奇迹，就像电影最初发明时那样。
On seeing the camera, she covered her eyes and ran back inside. "Get lost," we imagined her saying. But this was the beauty of video. Our mother retreated into the restaurant, and, against her better wishes, we hit the rewind button, drawing her back out. She was ours now. And we sat there for hours, none of us speaking except to say, "Do it again."
看到摄像机时，她捂住眼睛跑回了室内。“走开，”我们想象她说。但这正是视频的美妙之处。母亲退回餐厅，违背她的意愿，我们按下了倒带键，把她拉了出来。她现在属于我们了。我们坐在那儿看了好几个小时，谁也没说话，除了说：“再来一次。”
David Sedaris is the author of several books. His most recent is When You Are Engulfed in Flames.
大卫·塞达里斯是几本书的作者。他最近的作品是《当你被火焰吞噬时》。
[MUSIC - "PEOPLE TAKE PICTURES OF EACH OTHER" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - 金克斯乐队的《人们互相拍照》]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can download our podcast or listen to any of our old shows for free. Also, we have all kinds of merch in our online store. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里下载我们的播客或免费收听我们任何旧节目。此外，我们的在线商店里还有各种周边商品。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Torey Malatia, whose original idea for This American Life could be described this way.
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他最初关于《美国生活》的想法可以这样描述。
It was called Crazy News, and it was basically a newscast that was supposed to be crazy.
它叫《疯狂新闻》，基本上是一档应该很疯狂的新闻广播。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来。
Stay tuned next week when Darren Stein Productions present:
下周请继续关注，达伦·斯坦制片公司呈献：
Gay as a Whistle.
《像哨子一样直》。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。